[Music]  one is paltrow looking a fit and a fab  on the cover of a women's health  Australia I think that when um you know  you know yourself well and you've lived  a life with lots of ups and downs and  you get to be in your forties I think  you feel pretty good all the time the 44  year old that shows off her toned tummy  and a mesh crop table paired with some  super short running shorts that show off  her equally as toned legs inside the mag  the goop bounder gets candid about how  she deals with critics of everything she  does quote when someone doesn't like  something you do or doesn't share your  interest in something that doesn't have  anything to do with you she adds quote  the only time criticism hurts is if you  have a judgement about yourself about  that very thing you have to constantly  let go so you have to let go of old  ideas old resentment